they're coming to Amsterdam I was
thinking about the subtitle of this
symposium that ends with the words in a
dispirited age so this is supposed to be
a disputed age and I was remembering for
for the hundredth time wonderful some
wonderful verses by William Butler Yeats
from a poem called the second coming in
which he says Wallace the best lack all
conviction while the worst are full of
passionate intensity so in a way if I am
dispirited I'm quite happy to be
compared to the one who are spirited now
I would like to make sort of defense of
a term that has been used in the very
interesting debate between mr. Dougan
and mr. levy that is the word Nicholas
or Nicholas I feel I am one and I'm not
proud and not ashamed to be at least in
the sense that I am very different
towards values any kind of because you
know values can be very dangerous and as
the poem of Yates says the passionate
intensity in believing in something can
be very dangerous
I taught and I teach to people who
belong or belong to criminal
organization who were full of values who
had values for everybody of us and say
faith they were faithful men and
passionate so if this is a
spirited age we should at least the
defend for a while our sickness our
weakness our doubts our being our
lacking of convictions
instead of having one every once -
strong and dangerous I have a question
for you I think that it's clear it's
obvious that beliefs and values and
convictions can be abused and can be
perverted and that evil can be committed
in the name of values that purport to be
good I think this is certainly
historically true and etc but would do
you really think that a life without
belief is preferable to a life spent in
clarifying the difference between true
belief and false belief or good belief
and bad belief in other words I I have
family too I can't imagine how I could
raise my son on an absence of conviction
and my question to you is it is true
that sometimes some food is some
sometimes you are given meals that are
very terrible and that it can even
poison you and kill you but for that
reason would you stop eating entirely
would you give up all food because some
food can do you harm I I don't I'm not
sure I understand what you're arguing
for maybe it was it has been a miracle
with my family but I I had never to
teach to my children values like respect
the others or and all kill the other I
had just to say to them go and wash your
hands
[Applause]
what is it that you learned about human
nature teaching those pupils of you in
prison with wide why the question well I
I learned what I knew before going there
that the human nature is bad and so you
have to do your best to prevent to
limitate the damage that man can do to
other men or women and that's all our
duty not much more than these two two to
put down the the pain and suffering and
but because it because the evil is is
there is longer sees us if the if the
ban would be would be perfect there were
much use in making such great a fort
I I had a very very strange conversation
when I was working 15 years ago in
Afghanistan with with the as a volunteer
of United Nations and together with
other people were making my same job and
I was the only one to think that the man
was bad and we are we were surrounded by
distraction so what are we doing here if
man is not bad we have proof of of this
I don't agree with you I mean it's too
fatalistic to say man is evil I mean
there's a of course there's evil but
there's a reason why this evil existed
and I think it's all and the childhood
it so it's all in I think that the the
source of evil in the world is unloved
childhood is neglected childhood we
cannot just deal with it every day as if
it was a fact of life we should go to
the heart of the problem and start
working on it
I think it would be too fatalistic and
cynical to just say evil is there we are
wired for empathy we are wired for love
we are wired for feeling the others I
don't agree at all with with your vision
of of humans
you